lockdowns and social distancing may slow
the spread of this pandemic but they
will not beat it no emergency orders
from our leaders can save us over time
only medicine will stop this threat only
hope is science at the moment thousands
of doctors lab technicians chemists and
biologists are working to create
effective treatments for coronavirus at
some point they'll likely develop a
vaccine for it that could be a year from
now though
in the meantime researchers are taking a
second look at drugs already in use for
other diseases and there have been we're
happy to tell you some promising
developments so far five appear aveer is
a Japanese antiviral drug that's been
used to treat influenza among other
things an early clinical trial in China
showed improved outcomes for those with
mild cases of coronavirus REM des aveer
is a drug originally created to fight
Ebola scientists say it has shown
promise - so have low P nevere and
ritonavir those are two HIV drugs all of
these medications are being studied
right now in a major international trial
it's being overseen by the World Health
Organization here in our country a drug
called hydroxychloroquine has received
by far the most attention
hydroxychloroquine is most commonly used
as an anti malaria medicine you may have
taken it if you traveled abroad it's
been approved for use in this country
for 65 years it is cheap it's considered
safe a month's supply of it cost about
20 bucks so in a lot of ways
hydroxychloroquine is the ideal medicine
if it turns out to be an effective
treatment against coronavirus things
will change fast in this country and for
the better
is it an effective treatment we don't
know that scattered reports from health
care providers across the country
including in New York City today suggest
that it may be it's currently being
prescribed in France released one
studies suggests that it works in an
interview yesterday dr. Anthony foul she
said that quote of course he'd be
willing to try hydroxychloroquine on
coronavirus patients if you were
treating them directly a patient in
Florida credits the drug for his rapid
turnaround more trials are currently
underway including one in New York the
epicenter of the outbreak here and
actually this is how science works works
incrementally in different places at the
same time and in the end effectively if
you let it at the very least we should
all be
following developments in
hydroxychloroquine zoos with interest
and measured hope why wouldn't we be
well here's why Donald Trump is for it
several days ago the president expressed
confidence in hydroxychloroquine as a
treatment for the epidemic that was it
for the media if Trump is for it
they're against it even if it might save
American lives what reactive children
they are and they immediately began a
sustained push to discredit the drug
long before the clinical results were in
CNN ran a story accusing the president
of quote peddling unsubstantiated hope
in dark times
NBC News parotid the line blasting Trump
for selling quote false hope is it
possible that your impulse to put a
positive spin on things maybe giving
Americans a I think that I think it may
work and it may not work and I agree
with the doctor what he said may work
may not work I feel good about it well
in the midst of this propaganda blitz a
man in Arizona died after eating fish
tank cleaner that contained chloroquine
as an ingredient and that was it
something the President himself had all
but murdered this poor guy with some
quack medical cure called chloroquine
here was CNN's description of it a
game-changer that is how President Trump
describes the anti-malarial drug
chloroquine it's now one of 69 drugs
being investigated as potential
treatment against coronavirus the
problem it has not yet been approved in
an Arizona one man has died after an
apparent attempt to self-medicate with
that drug so during the course of that
segment by the way Sina never mentioned
that the man ate aquarium cleaner and
not medicine they lied about the
substantial in fact the central facts of
what happened because they thought it
might advance a political agenda then
they inform viewers that Trump was also
killing people in Nigeria John after
President Trump tottered the use of
chloroquine as a possible treatment for
covert 19:3 Nigerians have
the dust from that drag according to
Nigerian health officials now keep in
mind this isn't a tax bill they're lying
about it's a potentially life-saving
medicine that we are desperately trying
to evaluate in the middle of a global
pandemic and it's not just CNN that's
doing it
consider this bloomberg news story from
last night quote chloroquine know better
than regular coronavirus care study
finds that was the headline and it
sounds definitive why are we wasting our
time with this crap it doesn't work but
take a look at the details inside the
piece the story turns out to be based on
an article in the Journal of Zhejiang
University in China the Chinese study in
the article considered a total of just
15 patients 15 who've been given
chloroquine it seems like an awfully
small sample for a legitimate study and
in fact the story does concede that it
was quote the results of the study
weren't statistically significant
researchers concluded that additional
studies using larger numbers of patients
are needed in other words the story
doesn't really tell us anything so why
is Bloomberg News writing about it later
in the story you learned that in
contrast to the protocol in that tiny
Chinese study doctors here in the West
are administering hydrochloric win' with
antibiotics and that combination the two
of them hydroxychloroquine and
antibiotics appears to be effective and
that raises the same question once again
what exactly is the point of Bloomberg
so-called news story the way the Chinese
use the drug had nothing to do with the
way we are using it here the study is
irrelevant writing about it doesn't
illuminate anything it misleads that's
the point they're manipulating you this
is what happens when science becomes
political suddenly people start lying
and you can't trust anything you hear
that's a very dangerous thing to do at a
moment like this
the truth is essential just yesterday
that a governor of Nevada Steve Sicily
issued an emergency order that banned
doctors in his state from prescribing
hydroxychloroquine as a treatment for
coronavirus unless it's administered in
a hospital setting now sis lack is a
politician he's not a doctor
but he didn't hesitate to pronounce the
drug quote unproven as a treatment for
coronavirus well that's true
a technical matter but doctors prescribe
medicines in new ways all the time
it's called off-label usage it's legal
and very common in places where
Democratic governors don't decide to
micromanage the details of medical care
so why did sis elect do this his
statement suggested that
hydroxychloroquine was somehow a threat
to public health but the real reason was
likely the opposite of that the governor
was afraid of running out of it
pharmacist across the country reported a
large increase in requests for the drug
some of the requests have come from
doctors who appear to be stockpiling it
for themselves and for their families
this resulted in shortages that is a
problem and it's a problem for a number
of reasons including because the drug is
also used to treat chronic diseases like
lupus and rheumatoid arthritis but
there's one thing that it does prove
conclusively Donald Trump is not the
only person who thinks
hydroxychloroquine might be effective a
lot of practicing physicians think so
too our leader should be clear about
that
and yet many of them are lying about it
at a time when we are desperate for the
truth the thing we need above all is the
truth